- And I love this too, though.
You named your son is, after Milo?
I always say, it's Ventimiglia, right?
- Ventimiglia
- Okay, Ventimiglia.
It's such a sexy last name.
I always forget how to say though
but you named your son
after or him, is that true?
- Yes, it's true.
- Why?
He's great, I love him
but why?
- Because my husband,
before we were dating,
- Yeah.
- was Milo's agent
and came to visit us when we
were shooting "Pathology".
- Oh.
- And noticed that my husband
and I had chemistry,
we weren't even dating,
we were just friends
and Milo was like, "You
should, you should date Dave."
I was like, "I can't date Dave."
And he's like, "Why?"
I said, "Well, I dated
his really good friend,
so I don't know, it's not."
He's like, "It doesn't matter."
- Oh, you're adults.
- You're-
Right.
- Yeah.
- So, long story short,
Dave and I fell in love.
And so when we were pregnant,
I was like, "You know,
I've always loved the name Milo"
and Dave's dad's name is Miller.
So,
- Oh.
- on the birth certificate,
Milo is actually Miller
and we just modernized it.
And then we found out later
that Miller's college
nickname was actually Milo.
- [Audience Member] Hey!
(audience applauds)
- Oh, my Gosh.
- Isn't that incredible?
So, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- So, my son is named after
Ventimiglia and his grandfather.
- I love that he's like
setting people up too
and it works out.
- I know.
- That usually doesn't.
- He's such a sweet,
sweet, sweet talented guy.
(Kelly laughs)
But usually I feel like
when your friends are like,
"You should date", I'm like,
"No, you don't know me."
(Kelly laughs)
I'm like, "No."
- I know but I feel like
also they do know you, so.
- I don't know.
- No?
- My friends and I have
very different tastes.
(Allysa laughs)
They like those
Abercrombie and Fitch boys,
you know what I'm saying,
nothing wrong with 'em,
(Allysa laughs)
but they're very pretty.
And I'm like, "I don't
want somebody spending
in the bathroom longer than I do."
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying,
I'm, just like, "Yeah."
- But that's why I never dated actors.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's
why, yeah, I'm like,
"I need a little scrub."
- I don't wanna fight
for the tweezers.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- In the morning.
(Kelly claps hands)
Nope, like I'll walk
- That's amazing.
- into the makeup trailers
(Kelly laughs)
and like the actors are like,
plucking their eyelashes.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah, and I'll be like,
"Now I have to kiss you?"
Like you just spent more time
in here than I ever have.
- Yeah, that's gotta a turn on
for me, yeah.
- Me neither.
- Not me either.